[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari Seoul I'm
a pianist composer and on my channel I
create videos covering a variety of
subject matter when it comes to music
everything from composition piano
technique studying different genres and
also breaking down different composers
styles that series is called how to
sound like and I covered Franz Liszt
last year
how to sound like franz liszt if you've
seen the video already you may remember
that I referenced a trip to Lima to
research more on Franz Liszt all those
great musicians came to Weimar to this
really tiny place and and and they were
creating great works I mean you could
take this sheet and play it because it's
really so neatly it was an oval
character he never made a break every
year this is a last instrument from
Franz Liszt
he like like my barrel is a line and
then lists partners the line in vimar I
synched up with two of my really good
friends Jose Sevilla and Julius Meltzer
they looking for members like ok can I
join
yes sure the moment I find out I could
joined the list society this trip
wouldn't have happened without Joe help
fund it and organize it so thank you so
much Joe and also to Julius thank you so
much for helping translate for us I
don't know what we would have done
without you and of course to all of the
different experts involved now
throughout the video you'll see a lot of
new faces a lot of people coming in and
out basically a lot of people helped out
in this whole trip so I will provide
links to their websites or other places
where you can find more information
about them this building is called the
iton ball camp and lift lift here from
1848 till 1861 was not an Indian by my
office is one OK because let's travel so
much he got to know a lot of people and
potential students and but he didn't
recruit them they got to know him and
then chose to come to Germany to be his
master sent if you not a pianist or a
musicologist people don't know so much
about this
career late career began in the 70s 80s
miss Brenda who took that and found how
modern econ forced yeah
this was theory newer as a more than
even Wagner was the list founded a lot
of new sounds and he was a friend was
hector berlioz who founded in in france
this new technique for orchestration and
so so indeed the list knew a lot about
those things and so he brought it to my
mind he he worked that and not only to
rhyme attitude to the world actually you
can up until this point music history to
me was something quite static it was
something confined to a few pages in a
music history textbook and being
environments that had a lot of
information and a lot of passion
regarding these subjects looking through
artifacts of these composers going
through their things their homes walking
in the same streets that they did this
just changed my whole view of what it
means to learn about the history behind
the music that we all love and perform
and study for 12 years for 2009 yeah
yeah so if he would be in this year's
you could go in and say I am NOT a soul
we have all the music of the departs
from the orchestra parts or little the
parts from from from these compositions
with the marks of the composer's and
this is a great value for us as
musicians to just to look at it and and
to study them so he was this is his
handwriting this was the very first time
I was able to see a manuscript up this
close without a piece of glass in front
of me and it really helped me
just imagine list as a living breathing
figure who once sat at a desk or piano
and was writing down his ideas on paper
making revisions there's so much
personality in his penmanship
everyone's penmanship so you can really
get an idea of his character and his
process
and a lot of this is lost when you look
through a freshly edited and cleaned up
Edition this is really interesting
because this reveals something about his
composition process that it means he
wrote the notes first and afterwards he
did like staccato and the Christianity
and afterwards you cared about look here
it was so important for him that you
play it with your pinkie like he
actually wrote like a boy and you like
to play with your first finger
he was Sony but then he wasn't too
accurate if he said like there's just
something I have to do
yes essentially that's nzl ah why does
he have a lot of petal markings in all
the sketchbooks this wrote many
quotations and accepts as a from
literary well yeah this is a French poem
and this is a excerpt from a poem for
Tudor Corona this is the first draft to
tassel lamento eat your own food so he
actually started with the beginning 49
many things I think for the longest time
I took for granted the fact that a lot
of these manuscripts are available to us
just with the click of a button on imslp
a lot of times within the page where
you're looking for a specific score
you'll see the link to a manuscript
since two weeks so sketchbooks and the
sketchbook you can see online online in
da da Archie flatten bangle or nine
this is the future future music
revolution ayzik and as long as that was
breaking oh
so this is three years at tears at the
ship and died they wrote this biography
yeah
the Caroline wrote it you don't know we
didn't know I started in the Paula night
polonaise is in the blobs because he was
like the press that he died he was
really depressed I mean yeah like it's
crazy that he wrote this he didn't write
many things about composers but share me
my dear friend belly oz row to list two
of the most important composers in the
history and they were exchanging ideas
and saying like there's been a famous
town what because listed two
transcriptions of his work Harold in
Italy and seventies yeah I think he was
the company stand teacher who knew the
most music of Europe and over Europe
outside of Europe ever in his time I
think nobody knew so much foreign music
like listed he adopted a lot of pieces
of other people for piano yeah it kind
of is a kind of CD player no they had no
radio they had no CD they had no discs
so this is this team saw the
transportation of Wagner's operas of
barriers of Beethoven symphonies we did
anything actually funny
but recently when I was chatting with
Julius he said something that I thought
was so interesting he said that by
studying a list and learning more about
lists all of a sudden all of these other
composers surrounding him during his
time and who came after him their
contributions to music and their music
in general started to make a lot more
sense because somehow this figure does
one man was responsible for connecting
so many different parts of this whole
ecosystem of composers at the time this
really was a pivotal point of musical
and cultural influence he supported his
early supporters and played a major part
that attention was put on historical
figures the biggest one arguably being
the [ __ ] vogner basically said what you
are doing is truly the most futuristic
and amazing thing I've ever heard and
I'm gonna dedicate the rest of my life
to Japanese he actually like forged a
fake passport for vogner to escape
Germany like list is responsible for not
just a success but also his living then
the influence by and on Berlioz is so
strongly present as we've seen that
Berlioz developed sketches and ideas for
lists on compositional ideas and there's
panini and chappal letter playing a key
role in this development to become a
romantic composer at the time when Liszt
was here Paganini was out here and and
all those guys there who - did they were
they were virtuoso aldia they were
playing and and on top of that they were
composers
yeah and he goes I'm taking you guys
with me this specific trip led me down a
path that made me more curious about
other composers in this fashion I wanted
to learn more about the context
surrounding all of these different
composers and the progression of how
music over time over these centuries has
evolved and why scientists was the one
who demanded actually a professional
music school he was forcing that and
there was a guy called mulatto he found
it and at school called Orchestra school
and this is very famous for Vienna
actually because it is the orchestra
style I like you used the bow together
and so this was found it actually here
my mom was that not common before
yeah at the old time start of our rules
like anub arak time or in the classical
time as a first Boeing and for Strings
was it just didn't make science and they
didn't do it together all the time as I
did they played like the roots were
probably event it was heavy you played
down bow yeah if it was like to play up
oh yeah so like this and and then but
but then it was quite a mess sometimes
there was a need for for stronger rules
and and then one decided to make the
bowing together the you mention of the
prog music is very important and that's
why list and many composers sheds knows
we appreciate what it is yes because it
gave the possibility not to compose in
the traditional forms of a symphony but
in a new form which was one piece not
for we call it also as a double function
forms as are the free dance man swathi
one specific thing I started to look
more into was list contributions to the
very early stages of a tonality in
music in western classical music because
a lot of his later works really started
to push the boundaries of tonal harmony
at the beginning at the end you don't
have the tonal kee missa augmented right
here
okay
no Hungarian okay how many people were
so scared to walk up these stairs so at
this point something really unexpected
happened we didn't see this coming I
tell you this is the last instrument
from Franz Liszt and you are invited to
play a little bit I didn't think I'd be
able to touch his piano let alone play
it so to be given this opportunity was
quite amazing is it like it's light and
springy
[Music]
what was this written previously att
[Music]
I was a little uncomfortable
there's something really eerie about
sitting at his piano touching the same
exact keys that he himself once touched
and hearing the live sound of the piano
it's hard to put into words but it just
created this emotional shift in me and
my relationship to list as a musician
myself and just my understanding and
appreciation from him and there's just
something to be said to put your hands
on composers artifacts and to be in
their setting such an intimate space
where they once made music taught music
and lived and breathed
my hope and sharing all of this is for
anyone watching to perhaps consider
different approaches when it comes to
learning more about music history can
you appreciate a piece of music as a
performer or listener just music
appreciator without knowing any context
surrounding a piece of music yes
definitely you don't need to know who it
was written by when it was written why
it was written all of that and
appreciate the beauty of the music but
there's also significance and tremendous
value in learning more about the whole
picture and that's something that I
realized for myself and it's really
transformed the way I approach studying
a piece of music and playing it so I
think there's just something to be said
about that I hope this was interesting
to you all and thank you so much to
everyone involved in this video again a
special thank you again to Joe Julius
and thank you so much for watching I'll
see you very soon they the fantastic
ideas Canada's Olympic games of the land
purchase system and what really early
international competition of losing
painting I loved it much Zepa actually
this is this very very virtuous and and
it's a good story actually about this
business leader multiplier and it's very
very well made so so I love this piece
this is probably my favorite piece by
Franz Liszt first time he arrived there
was 21 steps to the top okay and he said
if this is gonna be an odd number of
stairs it's bad luck even number stairs
it's good luck so he goes one two three
four five he goes 21 this is bad luck oh
really
yeah William Mason the same German
hooked
sign me up [ __ ] yeah one joy Oh